la superbe vue ballast a réalisé sur son
site un abécédaire posthume pour pierre
bourdieu en allant chercher des phrases
dans son oeuvre ses articles ses
entretiens pour la lettre f
ils ont choisi ça le problème que je
pose en permanence et celui de savoir
comment faire entrer dans le débat
public
cette communauté de savants qui a des
choses à dire sur la question un ravin
sur les banlieues le foulard islamique
car qui parle dans les médias
ce sont des soufis lauzon pour toute
compétence de l'agriculture de vagues
texte des gens comme alain de crottin
j'appelle ça les pauvres blancs de la
culture ce sont les deux miss avant pas
de réactiver qui se font les défenseurs
de tokyo non pas pour marquer la
différence avec ceux qui ont encore un
moteur je suis un peu abasourdi par la
violence et la justesse de cette
enchaînement jabbes crochets uppercuts
bourdieu c'est un peu le mohamed ali les
intellectuels
quiconque se met à étudier un lien à se
renseigner sur un sujet de société ne
peut être comparée devant les gens
invités pour en parler dans les médias
on pourrait relever comme dans les
nouveaux chiens de garde
les implications idéologiques de ces
invitations limité un petit nombre de
gens mais là ce ne sont même pas des
gens qui travaillent pour des banques ou
des marques de luxe qui viennent nous
expliquer que le capitalisme c'est super
alors pourquoi pourquoi d'un ton autant
la parole à des gens qui ne sont pas
compétents pourquoi toujours les mêmes
pourquoi sont ils si peu nombreux la
réponse allait peut-être bien politique
et économique quand même
l'intellectuel médiatique manie l'art de
la formule est de la provocation il est
devenu en quelque sorte l'incarnation du
concept de [ __ ] un clic le discours est
caricatural simplistes sans arguments
des démonstrations et presque toujours
polémique
donc ça fait le buzz ça attire de
l'audimat sans apporter de véritables
éclaircissements sur le monde dans
lequel nous vivons
bref ça met de l'huile sur le feu celles
et ceux qui adhèrent à cette vision de
la société en ressorte revigorer les
autres se sentent agressés parce qu'il
faut dire que nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux devant ses discours bas de gamme
bien sûr ceux qui ont été sujets son
intérêt dépité
espérée on se demande comment on peut
oser l'hôtel simplification on s'étonne
qu'il n'ait pas honte d'eux-mêmes
mais ce n'est rien comparé à ce que
vivre d'autres gens surtout celles et
ceux qui sont directement concernés par
ces prises de parole parce que la
diffusion médiatique conférer une
autorité est donc un poids considérable
assez disco et comme ce sont toujours
les mêmes qu'on les voit tout le temps
et qu'ils disent souvent la même chose
ça fini par légitimer des propos souvent
simplistes et parfois insultants en plus
tout ça a dit comme s'il incarnait le
savoir est l'un des rites et histoire de
prendre de haut ceux qui ne pensent pas
pareil c'est la force de la phrase de
bourdieu pour marquer la différence
d'avec ceux qui l'ont encore moins que
est en effet certains os emparés de
l'histoire de france de la question des
valeurs républicaines comme s'ils en
étaient les gardiens sans avoir pour
autant la moindre légitimité
scientifique et il impose ses discours
et des gens qui justement souffre de ne
jamais se sentir légitime tout ça pour
quoi
tout ça pour assurer une position de
pouvoir ont fait le mec super
intelligent alors qu'on a deux vagues
lecture et on prend tout le monde de
haut il faut garder cette analyse de
bourdieu dans un coin de sa mémoire et
surtout pour mes collègues enseignants
je vous invite à la diffuser je crois
qu'elle a quelque chose de rassurant
pour nos élèves et étudiants ça libère
d'un poids mais aussi puisque j'en
parlais dans cette vidéo est bien peu je
crois qu'il faut également la garder
sous le coude pour ces nouveaux médias
que sont youtube twitter ou twitch avant
une audience ça donne du pouvoir et
avoir du pouvoir
ça monte à la tête je finirai en
proposant un détecteur de bouche bée
consiste juste à se demander où est
l'humilité c'est pas compliqué que ce
soit en frais et zemmour convient alain
touraine ils font tous preuve d'un gros
manque d'humilité
leurs propos ne sont jamais prudent
jamais mesuré jamais cadre assorti du
tout et toujours affirmée avec un aplomb
déconcertant
comme si vous énoncé l'évidence que le
monde entier refusent de voir et qu'ils
sont les seuls à avoir compris ils se
positionnent comme des personnes à part
des visionnaires en fait c'est un peu
comme si vous êtes doté d'une forme de
génie qui garantissait la pertinence de
leur discours comment font-ils pour
essayer de donner cette image d'eux
mêmes
c'est facile c'est ce que pointe
bourdieu en étalant une prétendue et
auditions en faisant par exemple comme
s'ils étaient
les héritiers directs de montagne ou de
nietzsche mais on ne rappelle jamais aux
spectateurs qu'il ya des gens qui sont
effectivement spécialiste de tel ou tel
sujet et que ces spécialistes ne donne
aucun crédit à ces pseudos intellectuels
pourtant quand on les voit à la télé ça
donne l'impression qu'ils maîtrisent
leur sujet merci la rhétorique
la dernière chose à pointer c'est qu'il
se présente souvent comme les porteurs
d'une vérité qui dérange
heureusement qu'ils sont là pour révéler
la mascarade et faire tomber les masques
grâce à leur cerveau hors norme et à
leur courage leur courage car c'est
aussi une affaire de vertu il ose
affronter la réalité que nous refusons
de voir ils disent ça si moi j'ai
compris
ceci est faux et la vérité c'est que mes
sentiments subversifs
en fait ce n'est qu'une position
rhétorique très souvent ce qu'il
présente comme subversif c'est un pichet
philosophique vieille de 300 ans
reformuler avec d'autres mots pour qu'on
ne se rend pas compte tout de suite ou
une idée qui est censé être dérangeante
mais qu'on entend pourtant tous les
jours sur ces news ou bfm les meilleurs
pour ça c'est onfray bhl et welbeck qui
se déclarent détesté par les médias
alors qu'ils y sont tout le temps bref
grande confiance de son discours et non
des certitudes est le seul à avoir
compris ce que tout le monde va devoir
se présente comme un penseur subversif